you have this chemistry you I didn't
realize that the the co-star your
co-star dolly wells yes she is your
friend in real life and you to play
friends on the show and it's it's such a
great relationship the two of you have
thank you well we do really like each
other yeah luckily right and we've known
each other for a very long time since we
were four that's so no I'm not gonna
tell you how long ago that was yeah a
long time ago you can tell when you
watch the show that these two really
know each other
Andy and I are actors played to be good
friends okay we were hired we trained
for a long time
I'm South African he just killed the
part so do you I know that you were
using a lot of your own stories from
your life autobiographical stories yeah
that you then get people to you then
work into this show going em yes about
your adventures and your adventures with
your friend have there been any that you
haven't gotten to use on the show yet
that you want to use anything that
happened to you in your life that's like
that would be great for this show yes
that things happen all the time that we
keep thinking we you know if we're lucky
enough to do another one we've got to
put in but there was one that we tried
to shoot in the first season that we do
ended up not having enough time for
which mash my husband was going to play
the part and he's the producer on the
show and I think he just didn't want to
do it so he he said we didn't have
enough time cut it out but this is
something that really happened it was
rare it really happened that I was I was
in my twenties and I was driving along
in my car and realized that there was um
a homeless person asleep on the backseat
who I had to notice when I got into my
car let's back it up just a little bit
you you you go we're even London at the
time I was in London I was I was it was
quite late at night it was in Leicester
Square and I went into one of those
underground car parts and I had an old
1960 Saab that I never bothered blocking
because it was just sort of falling to
bits and no one wanted to steal it so I
am anyway and I went off to my party
whatever it was and I came back
open the door got in and there was a
terrible smell it sort of I guess it was
pee and beer or something and I was
thinking god what is that smell and I
hope me and I was driving along wait I
love it you just keep you just are like
what's that horrible stench of beer and
urine well time to go it must be the
carpark I didn't anybody a little bit
out to the car but it was still there
very much there and then when I stopped
at the red lights and then there was a
man fast asleep on my back seat so he
came along I was looking for a place to
sleep like a bear and he opened your
back door and went into the back seat
yeah no yes
Wesley yes was he was fast asleep and
there was that there was about five
horrible minutes where I was driving
London with this man asleep from my
backseat and I kept looking at him
rearview mirror thank you I don't know
what to do how is this guy I know I know
what you do and you pull over and you
run out of the car
the wire why are you driving around
because at one point he was like Kate
driving it helps recently the sound of
the engine I dug by the way that's our
best British accent so what happened
eventually he woke up and he just open I
screamed and he screamed and I stopped
the car and I mean I can't really
remember but I just think I just opened
the door and out he got and that was
this right well he's like well this is
me zero nothing Avenue that's me that's
true enjoy the urine smell wasn't me
yeah you thought all that whole time at
that party I smell urine that's the
Cologne I wear